and now to present the award for the
best actress in a supporting role mr.
Jack Lemmon
jacket certainly is wonderful to see you
and I would like to take this
opportunity to tell you that I am one of
your greatest admirers
well jg5 uh I don't know what to say
just read the teleprompter like
everybody else it's easy
thank you you mr. Louis the nominees for
the Award for Best Actress in a
supporting role nominees for award best
actress in supporting role are Mildred
Donna Kim baby doll Eileen heckard in
the bad seed Mercedes McCambridge and
Giants patty McCormack in the bad seed
and Dorothy Malone in written on the
wind the envelope please
Dorothy Malone and written on the wind
thank you all so much I'd like to I
don't know how much time we have but I'd
like to accept this award in the name of
my late little brother bill and I'd like
to thank especially the Academy because
I'm sure that this year the four other
girls such stiff competition it was real
I really appreciated and oh I know I
haven't got time to thank such loyal
friends is Edna binoy and my producer
mr. Zhuge Smith and Universal all it's a
board of directors who've been had such
confidence in me like mr. moe
and I want to thank this the screen
extras guild and the Screen Actors Guild
because we'd have a lot of ups and downs
together and you understand all the pros
I've worked with thank you so much